good morning everyone today 20 you meet me i
am luca raffaello today i am with a
special guest called emanuele
marini who we have already met in
budapest
at the budapest conference and he speaks
many languages we also made an inter
sting video for youtube in which he spoke
15 languages if  I'm not mistaken 16 years
have lost control she remembers more
and today for grandmothers you remember and today
we will talk about how to learn languages the secre
s of this extraordinary polyg
ot then dear carmelo it is first
of all how it goes there in Bergamo well thank
you all r
ght thank you also here
o  madrid i'm in madrid for a project
for a secret project let's say in madrid
it's a drag c so dear emanuele
first of pitti man the question a
passage might seem trivial but
in your opinion how is it possible to
speak 30 languages how to learn langu
ges cdc us  tell how you learned
your first living foreign language let's
also tell them my first foreign language
that you do not predict  is from the
school curriculum because we still had
English Latin compulsory it was
German the politician in particular
Polish is a language that I love very much and
I will show you my endowment of
vocabularies and books
so first of all I started
studying with the classical method foreseen
for Latin the  greek started
studying the grammatical and
syntactic morpho structure of the language
without paying attention to the pronunciation at the beginning also
because he did not have the possibility to
verify the pronunciation until
later when I had
the first chance to go to
poland and the interesting thing when
also  I received as a gift the first
vocabularies which were these I did
was to try to write sentences
at first out of context
I tried to write letters to friends
I also have business communications
simply by looking for words in the
vocabulary and looking for
verbal forms on the spelling vocabulary  irregular
which imposes ques  to noun but I was just trying
to understand how
regular verbs are declined in order to
write sentences with the least possible number of
errors nitrates cause you used
vocabularies and grammars at the beginning
popular grammars and everything and I translated
word for word there is no  it is also from the
husband in writing and then set
up your study learning on the fact
that you wanted to communicate things or for
work with your friends
if I understood correctly and then I had
the intention to go on vacation
there but before going to  vacation
I wanted to learn at least the fundamentals
from the language which then once on site
I practiced placement as if
it were an empty structure to be filled
with fragile words you
built the skeleton for your teeth and then I help the
secondary and secondary elements and when
you went  in poland you avoided
speaking any other language who
was not polish i guess is that obvious it
is very difficult to give a language if
there is some  friend who knows Italian
translates everything is another thing that passes
for English and all Italian into
English English I speak much worse than
Polish an interesting and curious thing
a moment I move away from the camera
but I would like to show you this  word that
I hand them to him I'll show you how
I actually go to a place
where I don't know the language well, for
example we have Hungarian but these are
new because I just bought it.
I still did not have command of the
language I kept in my pocket so when
I wanted to say something
I looked very simply for the word
in the
vocabulary it requires a little patience on the
part of the interlocutor but from its
effects even now but for example
Persian
when I was in Iran I kept the  my
vocabulary of people in my pocket and
I was looking for and I wanted to say I wanted to train I
can not swim I was saying for example I was trying to
swim that if he said no tarda e d  icevo
I can't I don't know how to swim in the mid a
bite-sized dinner wires and it basically implies
what you do and understand the skeleton
of grammar uses
of grammar books then uses of
vocabularies go on site using
carbonari but a question that I am
sure many listen to  many listeners
are interested and what is the secret
in your opinion to learn a language well
in the span of 12 years
you study once they started
language on every day when for
example at the beginning to the beginning necessary
especially if it is  a language with a
completely unknown structure as it can
be for me Chinese now as the
Polish animi
I followed the method from my
Greek teacher one hour as a medicine
one hour in the morning before meals an hour in
the evening after I pass it  I do even if the
morning helps a lot more than the evening
less and they say no to each other in the mouth
here he is
very good also because in the evening there
are always things to do remains  you
never know back you never really know a
tranquility instead in the morning
first we take out the vocabulary
and we begin to study
grammar or seventh art and this
grammatical approach makes sense
in the video we made but also
in life what I saw at
budapest many Poles because
especially Polish and Serbian
are impressed by the
production so how did you
improve the pronunciation and I
went several times always lanese in serbia
there is the advantage that the Slavic languages
Russian Bulgarian  in my opinion they
are easy to pronounce for a
native Italian speaker of northern Italian
now I would not be able to say of the
central and southern accents they have a plan
some problems but the Lombard accent
does not give any problem for the pronunciation
of the Serbian of the Polish and I have an
advantage while pronouncing
d  'Albanian English is an impossible thing for me,
very much like the
language that Fr.  more in difficulty
in terms of pronunciation in terms of
pronunciation the Danish without a doubt and
the English also the English difficult
because the Hungarian feels very difficult
from the point of view of the vocabulary the
grammar is not impossible and instead the
pronunciation is easy we have lara  in borgo
berga obviously pronunciation problems
even if I know too little to be able to
judge the trend the Turkish does not
give pronunciation problems to the Greek not even
Slavic languages the Spanish like excuse me the Greek
very similar to the Spanish as I prono
nce eh yes yes yes it is very similar too
like intonation because this
passion for languages especially Slavi
DVDs then Slavic languages because I simply ha
e many friends there I often go ve
y hospitable people I like food
I like places and also cheap
ecause going ten other belgr
de go ten times to London ther
it is a big difference also
from a technical point of view,
especially for the frequency of my
trips I would say and for the commonality d  the
divisions with my friends who live
in those places and for their
hospitality so thank you for which I
thank on time so let's say
that and this also leads to the
next question the fact of knowing how to keep
so many languages is also due to the fact
hat  you travel are always is
always around both travel very low very much
changed a lot in europe especially and they
keep daily contacts even for
work for me york the poles the languages
day these every day and vario
s and various languages during one day I could
take today's example today I have
already received emails in Greek in
French its passage in Turkish in Serbian in
Polish in Bulgarian then there is another
Turkish there is another Polish there is an
English there is a Russian who  nice logic and
then here's another important thing
sorry eh don't give in to the temptation to
speak english another language of
colors and contains wasting time it is better to
say sorry i am looking for the word but i
tell you because one vol  ta that I look for it and
pronounce it stays in a hurry so here
then about words you have a
particular memory or you think that you
learn words efficiently because
learning words is one of the pillars
many people have trouble remembering
words if you see a word  that you
remember it immediately or it takes 5 3
I have to see it and repeat it or use it at least
once including twice 25
storage stations remain in your head
and then remain in your head it happens to me that
maybe then if I go to
Slovakia now I have not been there since
a long time
the first two hours make me a bit
difficult but after the third fourth hour
of stay these words come back
to my mind the memory last year
went to armenia ravel plane they arrive
at 4 am because I was not in a
position to speak and  the next day i
wanted
a friend of mine it is already the third time i
was in armenia the word once did not
come to me they came to me
suddenly  it
came back to me eating it came back to my
mind I told him to javier last in the meantime I
don't know why we were eating kebab
so it takes a couple of hours 3 to
bring back everything
that is deposited and that is not forgotten
in my opinion not yes  they forget the languages they remai
in a dormant dormant phase but d
not forget tell me tell me then it is anoth
r important question in the senate that
use in this but also stubborn is not t
use English I wou
d do everything not to use E
glish on TV  in the opinion that I do not
like it, I believe that it is not necessary to
use a vehicular language because the
communication allowed by the use of
mother tongues or my own or the
recipient's languages is much more direct and profo
nd in treatment than the commu
ication mediated by a vehicular language becau
e  I have to think in English
so my English will be an English Italian
and the interlocutor a Polish English
so making the union the intersection
between the sets what
few ancient languages remain common languages that I have still studied lik
many Latin Greek and then ancient Heb
ew for theology this does n
t mean that I can speak towards Lat
n or Hebrew, neither ancient nor modern it j
st means that when faced with a Latin ver
ion of Greek I can
I better orientate the velatino pi Greek
with him but not to speak
modern Greek I speak it well instead you feel
the enthusiasm with which you speak the two
languages you feel but in addition to languages you a
e two three f
ur degrees I no longer reme
ber lost count and  then 2
from the Italian legal system is one
of the Vatican
legal system for which jurisprudence philosophy when
the Italian legal system and theology for
the Vatican system so
let's say yours is a passion
for learning in general not only
languages and the civil code  I like to
learn the articles by heart with
all the little things a learning
enough memon the drivers what
would you say with the final message are there
many other things to talk about
obviously time is limited
also because you too have to escape what
would you say to someone who is about to learn
a foreign language because in your opinion
the Italians as well as other peoples
within Europe and the world
speak are monolingual people  who
speak 30 35 it is possible for a
normal person to learn other languages
e they should do it is possible as I tol
you before the more you stand and learn the easie
it is to learn so it is difficult to learn
the first nine hours c lan
uages then from 10 to 10 up to
infinity in my opinion is so much we are
because as you count what would you suggest to
a person who is to separate a
first foreign language do not give a
first language oh well for good or bad
now English French German at
school almost everyone does it
you have to try  a motivation
needs a motivation because
in travel permits are travel and
the aversion to vehicular languages for other
could be  and
particular friendships or travels or work you need to
find a motivation that
gives enthusiasm without enthusiasm nothing is
done
and then as a method everyone tries his own
there are those who like more method based
on a lazy life says more
writing
the important thing is to find a constant rhythm
of every day
the commands of days after a
week is enough on the spot it
is more than 22 meters or two years of
study at home it
is true the opposite you have to be with people
who do not know other languages
common vehicular languages or that not the vehic
lar languages for the English part depends because if
ou and I are Italian out of six
rmenian and we have Russian in common, Rus
ian but also here you have to speak in Russian
s it is necessary then you have to
speak in Armenian  in at least for
me in Italian to lose alternatives internal
heard I would like to ask one last question
as people are not used to
hearing someone who speaks 30 languages
know and there are often many skeptics about
it  to the fact that a human being
can learn so many languages
d like to live how many languages do you know now for tho
e who do not know the European re
erence system of aa1 b2 let's say h
w many languages do you know at a level that allows
you to live not to survive but to li
e without
problems a country and then I wanted to
know if you have diplomas that are not
necessarily the proof
that one poles but in short having a
diploma c1 c2 lady tina language
still speak well otherwise you would not
succeed I think 12 15 languages to know
hem well
hen we are 4 diplomas  made
the greek it seems to me that it was c1
the Serbian c1 the Slovenian c1 c2 does not
remind me of the Polish c2
I would like to do Russian but a little expensive
so I will see hi fi and Milan we do well
I could do Bulgarian I could do Romanian
I could do Albanian I would like very much
l  'Albanian for which there are about
fifteen languages and surely I use this metho
of keeping vocabulary in my pocket so I
on't worry about n  do not know
a word because if it does not absorb it
I look for it and I say it
because I do not shoot you cannot carry
with you an online vocabulary that you no longer
use online vocabulary it
was in a wood in albania you find me
internet then let's use a
path together radius insertion line wood  in
albania, however, i do not think that it is not
in a wood in albania every day
for the first trips i am in small towns my
own villages i do not like very interesting cities
and then i do not like
very much going to hotels i prefer to
go with people to people
if  a life in a place where
there is no internet or when there is you need to find
other more efficient methods but you
do not necessarily have to internet at the
portavolari you from the global view
the habit haeness in optics in
words with many meanings for these
words  it is essential to have some
examples
otherwise you make barbie figures barbine wings
then give less i am and we could
go on for another seven eight or  re
because it is the first thing that we are passionate about
so I wanted you I wanted to thank you and
I was also thinking for your
future estimations because it is for example
the video we made in Budapest
having a great success do you think about making
a blog or maybe building  not a
channel on youtube but even that
could be interesting no no I
have no experience in the matter if I had
someone who gives me a hand at least at the
beginning you could do my
beautiful let's all of us
I'm a bit academic property
classical academic methods from the study  of
communication I am not very familiar
with blogs blogs and thank you very much for
the help you have given me so far it has been
very interesting a nice adventure
okay you need a Bulgarian grammar
said that I go I can get some when I
pass maybe if it comes
as it goes a lot  I will probably
move to Italy so if you come to
Rome and with pleasure if I pass by in
Bergamo so let me see from that  the
scenes and the quality of the accounts thank you very
much for this
interview the problem is to do a lot in
others the next one maybe in Polish
even if my Polish is not extraordinary
but maybe you can help me fill the can
hang provide support in grenade